buenas tardes la verdad es que es un
placer poder compartir escenario con
personas como las que habéis visto y
como las que nos quedan por delante he
pensado alguna vez que quizás desde que
somos pequeños nos enseñan las cosas
verdaderamente importantes que no nos
enseñan cosas que no están de los libros
en el que estudiar yo lo pienso en cada
momento desde bien pequeños nos dicen y
nos empiezan a plantear el futuro
qué vamos a estudiar rápidamente hay que
tomar la decisión que queremos ser de
mayores sin ni siquiera saber 7 ese
trabajo nos va a realizar o no nos va a
realizar una vez que terminó de estudiar
lo que dejó de estudiar y me incorporo a
mi mail al mercado laboral el trabajo
empieza otra carrera
me quiero comprar un coche que coche me
quiero comprar quiero tener el mejor
móvil de todos en mi bolsillo que casa
que retener el futuro
verdad que os suenan estas preguntas
no nos enseñan a que ese futuro
realmente no existe
es algo que creo que debemos cambiar
totalmente en esta sociedad una vez que
llega el momento y si todo eso ha salido
bien voy a querer independizarme
casarme cómo se llamarán mis hijos
es lo primero que nos preguntamos
siempre estamos pensando en el futuro yo
no soy una persona distinta al resto
nací en una familia wind mi padre era un
trabajador autónomo mi madre se
encargaba de la empresa de [ __ ] el
teléfono de atender a cuatro hijos
nacidos en un período de siete años yo
tengo dos y nueve imagino como cómo
podrían conseguirlo
menos mal que teníamos abuelos y los
abuelos siempre hacen un papel
imprescindible en cualquier familia
al final
en la vida siempre nos enseña en el
futuro y siempre queremos aprender de
nuestros errores
el pasado
yo es algo que intentó cambiar el pasado
no existe lo que hice ya no tiene
solución es algo que no puedo cambiar
tanto se hacerte como si me equivoqué el
pasado se ha ido se ha evaporado
repito no existe y es algo que nadie nos
enseña en nuestra etapa de formación
todo el mundo debería aprender a vivir
ese presente yo creo que además el
pasado sólo nos sirve para una cosa para
no volver a repetir esos errores porque
al final el que comete un error es aquel
que se mueve aquel que decide un día
cambia el rumbo aquel que toma
decisiones lo voy a explicar con un
ejemplo muy práctico de mi vida me casé
en el año 2012
mayor
yo quería ir toda mi vida nueva york era
mi sueño mi viaje soñado
mi mujer no era de nueva york empezamos
a discutir a ver las opciones de viaje y
al final nos dimos cuenta que se
combinaba un nueva york con un poco de
playa aparte de que nos iba a salir más
caro no íbamos a disfrutar ni de nueva
york ni de la playa
tomamos una decisión y decidimos irnos a
mexico y disfrutar de unos días de playa
pero sobre todo disfrutar de un país
distinto de una cultura tan
impresionante como la que nos ofrece
méxico
volver justo un mes después me quedé con
la bici
fractura en cuatro partes de la
clavícula izquierda
dos operaciones once meses y medio de
baja laboral
justo cuando empiezo a trabajar otro
cambio de rumbo en mi vida
la directora nombran directora una amiga
mía y me dice que quiere que sea su jefe
de estudios yo he decidido que si me
cuesta mucho en esta vida decir que no
nuevo trabajo nuevo nuevo esfuerzo para
adaptarte a algo nuevo cuatro meses
después nací van
a partir de ese momento todo vuelve a
cambiar
nuestro niño se convierte en la
prioridad
os podéis pensar las veces que yo me
arrepentido de no haber ido nueva york
muchísimas ahí está el primer fallo yo
no me alimento de los momentos que no he
vivido me elemento de los momentos que
he vivido y debería cambiar el concepto
pensar lo maravilloso que fue el viaje a
méjico y no pensar nunca más en que no
fui a nueva york
a partir de ahí me traslado al año 2015
termina un año que fue muy intenso y nos
vamos a la playa
deseando
decía y os quiero hacer ver mi padre
trabajaba mil horas y voy a decir que
exagerado lo digo al día 1000 horas al
día la sensación de unos hijos que no
veían a su padre durante el día
pero siempre tengo un recuerdo
antes de irse a acostar hacía deporte
y ese recuerdo se almacena en tu memoria
y nunca desaparece os decía que estamos
en el 2015 nos vamos a la playa y
lógicamente mi hijo se tenía que venir
mi mujer no me quedaba más remedio me la
tenía que llevar también pero encima del
coche venía mi bicicleta
quería hacer deporte todos los días
antes de ir a la playa mi objetivo era
salir a hacer deporte
según avanzaron los días empecé a notar
que las piernas no estaban bien
que me fallaban
sabes cuando más nos daba cuando me
tiraba al suelo con iván o cuando me
tumbaba en la típica tumbonas de playa
qué hay de qué hubieras hecho vosotros
vosotras
yo voy a comprar una más alta por
supuesto
a partir de ese momento me levantaba
perfectamente vuelvo a cambiar el rumbo
de mi vida en septiembre me ofrecen una
oportunidad de cambiar el rumbo y vuelvo
a decir que si jefe jefe de servicio de
deportes y juventud en la provincia de
albacete
digo que si cambiamos de domicilio nos
mudamos familia
y cambiamos a mi pueblo a la roda
cinco semanas después
y por casualidad o no yo no creo mucho
en las casualidades el director que
había dimitido director general de
juventud y deportes
me llaman y se acordó de mí que os había
hecho antes
no sé decir que no
maletas otra vez cambio de guardería y
nos volvemos a toledo
fijaros que para cuando me han
presentado
entrenador maestro
estaba en la federación apasionada del
deporte
era la cumbre en mi vida director
general de juventud y deportes con lo
que yo me había quejado a los anteriores
ahora tenía la oportunidad de cambiarlo
decidí que sí
no me arrepentido en ningún momento como
decían antes era el mejor surfero de la
playa estaba en la cresta de la ola pero
las olas piedras a eso a que cuanto más
arriba ha subido más dura la caída
dos semanas después
fijaros que es rápido periodo de tiempo
primer evento deportivo en mi pueblo
voy a dar el premio y entre un escenario
que no llegaba a medio metro intento
sufrir con un trofeo en la mano
no puedo
lo vuelvo a intentar y me caigo
podéis imaginar lo que supone eso con
las cámaras de detrás en tu pueblo con
la gente con tu familia con tus amigos
el lunes me fui al médico de cabecera
rápidamente me derivó en otro logo y
comienzan 5 semanas
intensa hace pruebas desagradables
que acaban el 13 de noviembre del año
2015 el día que cambió mi vida como se
titula esta charla muchas veces pienso
sea mejor o peor pero cambio
imaginar a un médico con su bata blanca
separado por una mesa diciéndote
tienes el a
yo no sabía lo que era en la enfermedad
de stephen hopkins australia y aprietas
un poco dice es esto es duro si además
lo endurece más y te dice te quedan tres
años de vida
y empieza a preocupar te puedes ir a
hacer el testamento vital todavía más
resuenan en la cabeza muchas noches
incluso podrás vivir más
puedes poner la silla de ruedas una
máquina que respire por ti
fue muy duro pero algo se conectó en mi
que hubieras hecho cada uno de vosotros
o de vosotros en ese momento 13 de
noviembre a 5 de la tarde yo me fui a
currar
tenía un acto y no dije que no no sé lo
que dije no tengo ni una sola foto de
ese día pero sé que ese día me ayudó a
estar donde estoy hoy sé que ese día
cambio en mi vida para siempre
a partir de ese momento comienzo una
nueva aventura quiero que a nadie más le
pase lo que le pasó a mí
que nadie más vuelva a preguntar qué es
la el a visibilizar la enfermedad me ha
apuntado a todos los eventos a todas las
entrevistas no digo que no a nada tengo
aquí la pulseta
que llevan puestas tantas personalidades
que se me olvida la cuenta los reyes
presidentes del gobierno nadal iniesta
gasol indurain mi pasión por el deporte
me ha ayudado a llegar a ellos
si conseguimos visibilizar conseguiremos
que la gente en paz y fe
que diga y que vea que eso nos puede
pasar a cualquiera de nosotros y eso
significa saber los zapatos que llevan
el otro
ver imagínense el primer día que no esto
publicó tuve que pedir ayuda para abrir
una botella de agua
es complicado verdad pero se puede hacer
con ayuda llegamos a cualquier sitio
con estas dos palabras visibilidad y
empatía conseguiremos que todo el mundo
colabore en lo que le pidamos comprando
una pulsera organizando un evento
participando en los eventos esa es la
única solución que tenemos para de
verdad conseguir erradicar cualquier
enfermedad si recordamos fondos
investigaremos y la investigación es
igual a solución desde aquel momento yo
me he convertido y creo que será mi
mayor defectos sin duda un poco egoísta
no quiero
que nadie disfrute ni un segundo de la
vida por mí me los pierdo todos para mí
soy muy egoísta hoy os voy a dejar
quiero haceros hoy un regalo un regalo
en forma de frases frases que a mí me
ayudan en mi día a día y que me gustaría
que algún día os pudieran ayudar a
superar cualquier dificultad que se
ponga por delante
nadie ha vivido mañana en mi frase de
cabecera yo estoy aquí estoy peor que
cualquiera pero que se atreva a levantar
la mano quien cree que mañana va a estar
aquí y yo no estoy seguro que eso es
imposible
gente pequeña en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas puede cambiar el
mundo os invito a que hoy salga desde
aquí siendo gente muy pequeña
a la línea de meta
siempre vais a llegar antes que yo pero
os garantizo que yo voy a llegar
no son los años de vida sino la vida de
los años llenar cada momento de vida
cada minuto
cada segundo cada día llegar lo de vida
es importantísimo otra de las frases si
yo pudiera pedirle algo a mis padres si
volvieran a hacer que me volvieron a
apuntar a hacer deporte apuntar a
vuestros hijos el deporte enseña valores
que nunca se olvidan y por eso os decía
que el deporte iba a ser una parte
importante poner ha sido en lo que
hacéis la pasión nos ayuda a mover el
mundo
sonreír sonreír incluso cuando no
conozcáis a la persona con la geo vais a
cruzar eso hace mucho bien a esa persona
pero os garantizo que los principales
que vais a recibir ese bien sois
vosotros y vosotras no busquéis gigantes
la magia de la vida está en las pequeñas
cosas
no no queráis ir a grandes cosas porque
muchas veces todos tenemos accesible el
llegar a algo que está muy cerca de
nosotros
por último
me llamo cuanta
nunca he estado en nueva york
nunca voy a estar en nueva york
tengo el a pero llevo tatuado en mi
brazo una frase con la que quiero hoy
salgáis llenos de esperanza de vida
y de felicidad acuérdate de vivir y
siempre siempre siempre adelante
muchísimas
[Aplausos]